we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p let's take a listen to this
voicemail that came in yes hello this is
dr. ben Carson calling you I am I
couldn't fall asleep tonight and I got a
midnight snack and I browsed the
internet and came across one of your
videos saying that I was not qualified
to be head of housing and urban
development yep um first off I owned a
house that I've lived in urban area
right and assertively I've developed my
house so you just don't know what you're
talking about yeah I just called to
correct but the record yes always great
to hear from failed presidential
candidate and upcoming Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development Bank arson
and indeed our suspicions were right we
said Trump might have selected Carson
because he grew up in Detroit and I
guess in Trump's mind even if you're
near neurosurgeon that makes you
qualified to head up housing and urban
development development and in this
voicemail of future secretary Carson
agreeing that growing up in Detroit is
part of why he's qualified you know why
I'm skeptical as that if this is
actually Ben Carson and I found it too
lively that Ben Carson would it have any
trouble falling asleep right now he
seems almost like he is trouble staying
awake not falling asleep on the bonus
show today China will attempt close to
30 space launches in 2017 Millennials
may be the first generation to lose a
majority of their jobs to automation and
the death penalty for Dylan roof the
u.s. Church attacker who killed nine
people I want to talk about that verdict
all of these stories and more on the
bonus show there's only one way to get
access to the bonus show we do a bonus
show every day if you like the regular
show stands to reason you would probably
like the bonus show and you can sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
of course if you want you can use coupon
code i voted 17 to get a
major discount off of membership